they're very much feeling the
computational constraints of the system
when you're creating these open ones and
you know what that's the thing then you
see some of it now but in those times I
do feel like every year the technology
moved and maybe it's because the same
thing we're like that might age at that
time where every year somebody was
coming up with some new method or some
new game system
and
it was every year that Innovation
Innovation Innovation and then you know
3D acceleration comes along and then
these things come along and then HD
comes along and it is true that as time
goes on there is visually a diminishing
return in terms of
what you're able to do on the screen and
it there's a ton of work that goes into
it now because just rendering this cup
to the perfect shine and material and
roughness and how does the global
illumination off this wallet gets a ton
of work
but you can pretty much do what you want
now if you want to put the time in
whereas then okay you can't do
everything you want
so pick your battles really carefully
and
it technically you couldn't do what you
want if that makes sense how much
trade-off is there now in um how much
effort you put into
the the realism of the graphics versus
the story and actually not even how much
effort you put in but is there um
a trade-off in the experience the feel
of the game
in terms of realism and story
usually we will start with let the
player have as much agency and do as
many things as they can as possible and
we will sacrifice
some graphic Fidelity for that some
speed for that you know we could make a
game that
you know our traditionally our games are
you know we okay with 30 frames a second
as long as it looks really good and the
simulation is running and all of those
things so we'll we'll sacrifice some of
that Fidelity for the player experience
in in this the kind of things that that
I do
um but from like a Manpower standpoint
the graphics programmers work on
Graphics the artists work on Art and we
have a you know awesome team of artists
and designers and writers and
programmers it's usually where we find
as time goes on the amount of art time
that it takes to create
a cup
compared to what it used to be that has
increased so we do use like most people
use you know art Outsourcing as well so
that we're not we still relatively
compared to our industry and what we're
doing have smaller teams what about the
experience of the beauty of the graphics
So like um one of the most
amazing things about Skyrim and maybe
you could say that about some of the
other games but for me Skyrim is the
Outdoor when you step outside yeah it's
the outdoor scenery so what does it take
to create the feeling especially of that
being outdoors of Nature and just like
lost in the beauty whatever it is when
you go hiking and you feel the awe of it
how do you create that all is that
Graphics what is that it's a lot of
Graphics it's a lot of mood we just talk
about it in terms of tone and those are
again going back to my previous comment
the graphics are very very important to
us because and we always push them
because when you're doing the kind of
things we do where you step into a
virtual world it doesn't have to have
that moment of wow
this is this feels real I've never
experienced this
and it's okay
I think it's okay to let just like the
time settle
meaning you step out
how does the wind sound
how are the trees moving how are the
clouds moving
um
I enjoy strolling and watching the
sunset
you know how does it land over the water
like it doesn't have to be like hey
let's go let's finish a quest let's go
kill things let's figure out the next
step let's level up like I like The
Quiet Moments a lot and I think when you
play our games you can tell we spend a
lot of time on them
um then you watch like the weather roll
in
um I think that's just part of being
being that character being that person
in that space
yeah the I saw that there's a mod that
removes all enemies I've been meaning to
do to do that to just do like a live
stream where for hours walk around
Skyrim just and then answer questions
and so on that just feels
um
that's a completely stress-free
environment it's just you are just like
you said in this moment in time and it's
so incredible it feels as incredible as
going hiking or some something like that
but in another totally different place
like an like uh Iceland or something
like that this this this whole other
surreal ethereal place it's uh yeah it's
incredible how you kind of create that
so Graphics is a part of that but also
letting it
uh the temporal aspect of that like the
when the the rustling sound and look and
all of that the soundscape is really
really important in the sky we spent a
lot of time on the sky because it's
taking up much more of the screen than a
lot of people give credit
before
what about the rendering the openness of
it is that there's a lot of level of
detail streaming work and if you know
nowadays it's getting more common like
frankly the systems are built better for
it
um hard drive speed is really
prioritized like they're so blazing fast
um he takes Skyrim and Oblivion and the
fallouts of that 360 era it's a it was a
lot of time spent on how do we get all
this data streaming in as you move and
then levels of detail so you can see all
the way
but not you know crush the processor